en bas âge l'accueil qu'international
maintenant après l'irak c'est
l'industrie nucléaire iranienne qui
inquiète l'amérique washington sommes
téhéran de donner des informations
précises sur son potentiel
suspectant la fabrication secrète d'une
bombe
le directeur de l'agencé internationale
de l'énergie atomique est aujourd'hui
dans la capitale iranienne qui pour
d'autres raisons est en effervescence
politique hervé ghesquière manifestation
contestation cela fait des semaines que
la rue protestent contre le régime des
mollahs de terre au malaise politique et
social s'ajoute désormais la pression
internationale sur la question nucléaire
est-ce que téhéran respecte le traité de
non prolifération
non si l'on en croit un rapport de
l'agencé internationale de l'énergie
atomique
aujourd'hui il s'agit pour les nations
unies de faire accepter par l'iran des
inspections sur les sites nucléaires
je pense qu'à long terme c'est dans
l'intérêt de l'iran de faire preuve de
transparence pour créer une atmosphère
de confiance
autre problème la possession par le
régime islamique de téhéran du missile
shahab 3300 km de portée capable
d'atteindre la turquie et surtout israël
mais alors la riposte serait immédiat
pouvoir que le rapport de force
militaire est très défavorable à l'iran
que israël et la turquie sont des alliés
des etats unis et qu'on voit mal l'iran
se lancer dans une guerre contre israël
sont faits à être complètement détruit
et vaincu le but des nations unies et
surtout de washington est donc de mettre
un terme au programme nucléaire
militaire iranien
mais pour l'heure téhéran reste sourd
aux pressions internationales